they used to quite often in movies to
have a fairly simplistic possibly but a
moral message of some kind or a very uh
aspirational quality to it like if you
think about movies from when I was a kid
whether you think you're good or not
like Independence Day or whatever it was
all about triumph over some kind of
foreign hostile Invasion people coming
together all over the world it was all
about uniting and working together to
succeed in some way whereas more
recently even in like stuff that I think
is incredibly well made whether that's
Game of Thrones or house of cards or
anything like that I started to see that
actually what they were doing now is
showing the opposite and going look at
all the Deep dysfunction in human beings
look at all the terrible ways that
people operate look at the way people
cheat and steal and and and murder and
do all of those horrible things and it's
shown from a a kind of different
perspective so instead of giving you an
aspirational picture it was it became
more about going look how bad everything
is well I think that that ties into the
mindset of a lot of uh the writers in
Hollywood now you know a lot of them
will have gone to college for four or
five years where they've been told
incessantly the world is inherently
racist and sexist everyone's awful
everyone hates each other it's just this
big hierarchy of people getting
oppressed by everyone else and so that's
going to reflect in their mindset and
it's going to reflect in what they write
and what they try to rationalize in
their stories and that's why you get
what you end up with and yeah it's
it is so disheartening because like you
say there used to be an aspirational
message to so much of of movie making
you know whether it was characters like
Rocky who have to to you know rise to
some big challenge to try and overcome
it whether it's something like
Independence Day like a big cheesy
Blockbuster movie but there's a positive
message there about people putting aside
their differences to to take on a bigger
threat
um unashamedly pro-american I suppose as
well um and that's again what you see
now is there's this kind of nihilism and
this kind of uh uh almost hatred of
their own country you know America was
never that good anyway and it was all
founded on on racism and slavery and all
that stuff
um it just it
engenders this kind of negative mindset
in the audience I think and they come
away unsatisfied by it I don't know if
the writer is in their way feel like
well we're making the world a better
place because we're educating people
about the problems of the world
but there's a format for doing that and
if you just focus on that you end up
just leaving your audience feeling
downbeat and unhappy and I think that's
why you know a movie like top gun
Maverick that came out it's a sequel to
a film from like the 80s you know it
should never even in in all
um you know in any rational World it
never even should have got made so long
um you know so many years later
um but there it is and it's and it's a
really good fun movie it's positive it's
upbeat it doesn't try and
um denigrate the past or put down its
previous generation of characters it's
respectful
um and it ends up just being a really
great fun movie and people come out that
feeling good about themselves what's so
bad about that
you know it's a lot we're allowed to
feel happy occasionally not anymore
mates yeah but you know sorry just on
this very Point Francis like you
mentioned for example slavery right
there's a history of movie is about
slavery I remember as a kid here at
school going to see amster Amistad and
that is a movie about a horrible chapter
in human history but it also shows that
people working together and people uh
advocating for their rights and and
freedom of Express all of that stuff can
actually achieve results is saying like
we're not doomed as human beings to the
worst elements of our past we're not
doomed to our most base instincts we're
not doomed to to be constantly stuck in
this endless eternal battle between
groups actually when we work together we
can get to the point of our common
Humanity actually trying thing over all
that tribalism yeah and now we're just
doing the exact opposite we're just
going here's here's another movie about
how we're all evil yes you know
uh yeah yeah I mean there's nothing I
can add to that like you've pretty much
articulate it perfectly it's the you
know it's the mindset now of making
movies but surely that's gotta that's
gotta be unsustainable you'd think but
they keep doing it I mean my my
rationale has always been uh eventually
the money will run out you know so many
of these movies that they try to do uh
they fail uh and they end up losing
money for the studio
um and you know as many
um ideologically driven people as there
are in Hollywood there's even more guys
who are just money men
they just want to make cash they don't
care what it is that does that but if
they see enough movies that are in the
red there there has to come a point
where they say enough of this crap we've
got to stop this we have to start making
movies that are actually popular that
people like
so you just you have to hope that
eventually it's going to filter through
I mean like you say there's there's
occasional films that um that do crop up
like like top gun Maverick that um that
have done really well and hopefully they
serve as a little
um You Know lesson for people
but it can still work it deals these
older style movies that are positive or
be patriotic whatever it might be
they can be a massive success if they're
done right
um we just have to hope that it'll
happen eventually
you know these are all excellent points
because I remember going to watch 12
Years a Slave and I remember saying to
my ex-girlfriend as I walked out I said
I think the only way you can enjoy that
film is if you are actually racist yeah
that's the only way because I
of some of the most horrific
people and you go this is this is put
this is obviously accurate all of these
things but you go this
it's just awful it doesn't leave you
with any any sense of you know of
anything apart from just deep horror
yeah I mean obviously different movies
are designed to do different things
the same right you watch it to get a
picture of what happened yeah you know
you're not walking out they're looking
for a feel-good moment yeah exactly you
can you know you can watch Schindler's
List you're probably not going to have a
blast watching that movie but it depends
on your political opinions but it's an
important movie yeah of course and it's
a it's obviously a deeply moving and
poignant film
um but not necessarily uh an enjoyable
film yeah but you know so I think
different films can do that but I think
the problems come in when you're
ostensibly trying to make some some uh
Blockbuster you know fun upbeat movie
and then you start working in this other
stuff like ah by the way do you know the
like loads of people in America are
racist or you know whatever it might be
um it's just it often comes across as
just weird moments of you're trying to
make something into something then it's
not